колеги Доброго дня
сьогодні
21 липня
і сьогодні рівно 4 роки тому відбулися
парламентські вибори
і незважаючи на те що сьогоднішній день
переповнений подіями це і відставка
такого знаєте батько української цензури
державної знищення свободи слова в
Україні
автора численних скандалів
медіа-менеджера Коломойського пана
Ткаченка
на фоні відставки
нашого посла великий Британії пана
пристайка
ні в якому разі не треба забувати що
парламентські сили мають звітувати
перед своїми виборцями і перед народом
України
і сьогоднішній день наш бріфінг
присвячений саме такому звіту і ми дуже
сподіваємося
що парламентські сили які подолали
бар'єр
і опинилися в Верховній Раді України
будуть слідкувати нашому прикладу і
також прозвітують
армія мова Віра
коли 4 роки тому ми резюмували нашу
каденцію президентську нашого
парламентську діяльність в минулому
скликанні після революції гідності
всі
нашого опоненти вважали що це є
передвиборча гасло
І лише зараз життя довело що це є
де-факто національна ідея
самоідентифікації українців
і на сьогоднішній день
воно перемогло
принципи дуже легко закінчити війну
достатньо просто перестати стріляти
війна тому що хтось на неї заробляє
Какая разница
термос замість томосу де це все
а армія мова Віра
сьогодні існує і сьогодні воно існує не
як гасло 25%. і не як гасло 73%
це є національна ідея 100% українців
української нації українського народу
і ми об'єдналися на цій платформі
Але до цього додалися дві дуже суттєвих
речі
це є НАТО
і те що ми внесли зміни до конституції
щодо обов'язковості до всіх гілок влади
робити все можливе для членства України
в НАТО і це Європейський союз на додаток
до підписаної мною угоди про асоціації
поглиблено та все охоплюючи зону вільної
торгівлі безвізовий режим
ми маємо бути в ЄС Я хочу процитувати
статтю точніше вислів одного з лідерів
країн-членів Європейського Союзу
коли відповідаючи на питання
А про що НАТО і про що єси чим вони один
від одного відрізняються
була геніальна фраза
НАТО
це життя
а ЄС - це краще життя і це абсолютно на
100% відповідає
щодо майбутнього України
Я Хочу наголосити що зараз армія мова
Віра ЄС НАТО дорівнює Україні
і на сьогоднішній день ми є
опозиційна фракція
і життя розділилося на до 24 лютого
22-го року і після
і до 24 лютого наші функції були
контроль влади
і презентація власного бачення розвитку
нашої держави
і цей контроль полягав і в тому що ми не
дали створити корупційний ковідний фонд
з якогось якимось дивом фінансувалося
будівництво доріг
зруйнували
спроби влади на велике кредівництво
не з самого початку не все вдалося але
ми були єдиною політичною силою які
боролися за те щоби всі Кошти які
вивільняються з ковідного з дорожнього з
багатьох інших фондів були спрямовані
перед війною на збройні сили України
почитайте і подивитися моє звернення в
жовтні листопаді 21-го року
почитайте і подивитися спільну позицію
фракції коли ми презентували 50
мільярдний законопроект який передбачав
доукомплектацію бойових бригад який
передбачав створення стратегічних
резервів які передбачав перевірку із
замінування чонгару який передбачав на
сьогоднішній день закупівлі нової
техніки я твердо переконаний що це могло
би зупинити Путіна якби
це повірили
і дуже висока ціна заплачена за це що
нас ігнорували Ми на сьогоднішній день
також наголошуємо на тому що
наш перший пріоритет зараз
це є армія
і 24 лютого
2022 року я потиснув руку пану
зеленському і чітко наголошую що зараз
Володимир
А я не лідеру позиції
класичному розумінні цього слова Ми
маємо об'єднатися і перемогти Путіна і
наша фракція повністю
рухається в цьому напрямку
армія є пріоритетом бо не було б армії
не було би мови
і сьогодні мова як державотворчі як
фундамент нації її захищає армію
бо не було би армії не було би віри і не
було би Віра була би але точно не було
би церкви і для того щоб в цьому
переконатися подивитися Надії
п'ятої колони Московського Патріархату в
Україні вони боряться з нами з державою
з народом за кожний храм А при чому
легко передають свої парафії своїми
митрополії в чотирьох областях які
окуповані
Які ще докази потрібні
і в цих умовах ми наголошуємо що зараз
ми будемо продовжувати боротьбу колеги
про Це скажуть але кожна копійка включно
з
33-ма мільйонами які хотіли вкрасти на
ганебних
паплюжачих Україну в серіалах будуть
передані до армії
кажуть на безпілотні літальні апарати на
дрони мені це дуже добре відомо Тому що
наша команда і мій фонд поставили до
армії
1000 квадрокоптерів
бо держава
витрачає гроші на серіал поставили
більше сотні посейдодів бо держава
витрачає гроші на серіал
нема чим возити евакуювати
в зоні бойових дій техніку і ми
поставляємо зараз 40 красенів малюків
ходенів які за півтори хвилини
розвантажують і вантажують чи
контейнерським боєприпасами чи підбито
техніку
і багато-багато іншого
і на сьогоднішній день ми будемо
ініціювати законопроекти які будуть
передавати з непрофільних державних
видатків включно з двома мільярдами на
єдиний марафон
армії
на Дрони на системи розмінування на
системи протиповітряної оборони і на
засоби радіоелектронної боротьби який
так не вистачає на фронті на броні
техніку Я пишаюся тим що ми поставили і
шилди
і спартани
До речі спартаментами мали поставити
десантникам
але нас закидали проханнями батальйонів
тероборони які були в бахмуті
які були під Мар'їнкою які були під
угледаром
тому що вони залишилися без евакуаційних
гусенічних броньованих машин і Ми
попросили десантники вони пішли нам на
зустріч і по одному спартану по одному
султану по одному самаритяніну в кожен
батальйон і я пишаюся тим що ці це
рішення врятували життя
сотням наших воїнів
і вже стільки заради цього варто жити
Я Хочу наголосити що ми
в Верховній Раді ініціюємо і підтримуємо
проєкти які підтримують благодійність
проекти які підтримують волонтерство
проекти які відновлюють справедливість в
тому числі і по відношенню до бізнесу
проекти які забезпечують і захищають
інвестиційний клімат і малий та середній
бізнес
ми будемо це робити
ми робимо це ми не допустимо бекслайдов
до реформ
руйнацію тих реформ які наблизили
Україну до Європейського Союзу за часів
нашої каденції це
децентралізація яка була визнана
найуспішнішою реформою і зараз
намагаються спроби її зруйнувати ми
єдина опозиційна фракція стаємо на
захист і не будемо мовчати проекти
реформи коли намагаються зруйнувати
систему прозоро і реформу державних
закупівель проекти які намагаються
зруйнувати систему
корпоративного управління коли за нас
всі державні корпорації були
прибутковими перераховуючи гроші в
бюджет А зараз є банкрутом проекти
паблік сервіс публічного управління
відновлення менеджменту проекти всі
проекти які перелічені в тих що
необхідно прийняти яку мови і для
отримання і початку переговорів по
вступу України в ЄС і до членства в НАТО
і Я дуже сподіваюся що ми зараз зробимо
Це все нас підтримують Головне що нас
підтримує український народ і уже на
вашингтонському саміті наступного року
саміті НАТО Ми отримаємо за запрошення в
цей єдиний блок який дозволяє зберегти
захистити Україну і мир в світі
нас в Верховній Раді небагато 27 бійців
але як ми казали під час парламентської
кампанії і зараз 4 роки це підтвердили
ми парламентські Спецназ наша сила в
командності де Один за всіх і всі заодно
де всі працюють в рамках спільної
стратегії і я пишаюся тим що я стою на
чолі цієї фантастичної фахової
професійної патріотичної
команди яка глибоко сконцентрована на
вирішенні проблем які дозволять нам
наближатися до армії мови віри ЄС НАТО
до українського народу його прагнень
Слава Україні
шановні друзі Добрий день шановні колеги
дійсно в 19-му році наша політична
команда ухвалила рішення з ініціативи
президента Порошенка в парламенті про те
що членство в Європейському Союзі і в
північноатлантичному альянсі є
стратегічними цілями для України для
української держави тоді багато хто
вважав що це акт політичного піару але
ми бачили як саме це рішення стало
реальним запобіжником проти зміни курсу
протягом усіх цих років ми ще в 19-му
році напередодні саміту у Лондоні самі
то НАТО у Лондоні наполягали на тому
що Україна має подати заявку на членство
якраз на базі цього рішення яке було
внесене в Конституцію тоді наші опоненти
говорили про про те мовляв ніякої
додаткової заявки нам більше не потрібно
ми бачимо що
наш професійний підхід виявився
аргументованим і в 22-му році українська
держава таки подала заявку на членство
північного Атлантичному альянсі саме
наша політична сила
спромоглася захистити присутність у
парламенті 9-го скликання Комітет з
питань інтеграції України до
Європейського Союзу бо наші колеги наші
опоненти воно більшість не вважали що
цей комітет який вже працює кілька
скликань у Верховній Раді України який
забезпечує
аналіз всього законодавства на предмет
відповідності право Європейського Союзу
нашим зобов'язанням Європейським Союзом
і який контролює виконавчу владу
стосовно виконання наших цих обов’язків
перед Європейським Союзом які ми самі
добровільно на себе взяли що він не
потрібен вважали наші колеги я вдячна
якраз команді європейської солідарності
яка на етапі входження в парламент 9
скликання відстояла те що цей принципова
річ і
делегувала мене бути очолювати цей
комітет Я вдячна за цю довіру І сьогодні
ми разом з Петром олексійовичем працюємо
в цьому комітеті відстоюючи наші
завдання євроінтеграційні які стосуються
і виконання подальшого угоди про
асоціацію а також нових речей які нам
спільно вдалося добитися Тому що наша
команда маючи неймовірно високий рівень
розгалужених міжнародних зв'язків з 24
лютого 22-го року активно включилася в
захист держави через взаємодію з нашими
партнерами ми переконані що наш
впевнений аргументований голос додав до
Голосу України яка була почута нашими
партнерами і маємо серйозний внесок
нашої політичної команди в забезпеченні
України зброєю в забезпеченні України
гуманітарною фінансовою економічною
допомогою у
розвої і розвитку санкційного режиму і
тиску проти російської федерації проти
Білорусі так само і будемо продовжувати
цю роботу Ми дали десятки тисяч у всіх
спільно інтерв'ю міжнародним медіа
пояснюючи що відбувається з атакою
Російської Федерації проти України ми
використали свої зв'язки і в рамках
членства нашої політичної сили
європейської популярності в європейській
народній партії в міжнародному
демократичному Союзі наші депутати
активно і ефективно якісно працюють і в
парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи і в
парламентській асамблеї НАТО і в
парламентській асамблеї ОБСЄ і в
міжнародному парламентському Союзі Ми
вони обіймають провідні позиції на
міжнародних цих майданчиках І ми також
активно просуваємо наш порядок денний
через парламентський комітет асоціації
тобто через зв'язок з Європейським
парламентом і вважаємо що
наш внесок в те що Україна отримала
кандидатський Статус є абсолютно і був
абсолютно критичним і зараз продовжуємо
працювати над тим щоб перемовини щодо
членства України в Європейському Союзі
були відкриті вже цьогоріч А для цього
мусимо не тільки працювати з
міжнародними партнерами а і максимально
мобілізовувати наших колег у парламенті
України для того щоби парламент таки
виконав сім умов які супроводжували
рішення про кандидатство
прикро усвідомлювати що наш голос не
завжди чують колеги коли ми застерігали
стрибуни Верховної Ради В грудні місяці
2022 року про те що законопроєкти які
ухвалюються нібито на виконання умов про
кандидатство в Європейському Союзі вони
робляться недосконало вони не
відповідають вимогам ні Європейської
комісії ні венеційської комісії наші
колеги тоді усміхалися через 8 місяців
Так як ми і попереджали нам доводиться
це переробляти Я дуже сподіваюся що
через наші ініціативи через наші
поправки через наші вдосконалення які ми
пропонуємо на вдасться таки виконати ці
пункти ці умови якісно для того щоб
українці а не мали з марнованого шансу
який сьогодні цього вікна можливостей
які сьогодні відкривається перед
Україною шлях перед нами ще великий але
ми маємо як перед країною для того щоб
пройти до членства і в ЄС і в НАТО але
ми переконані що наша професійна команда
може якісно далі провадити цей шлях для
України і українців дякую
відбудова країни залежить від
інвестиційного клімату саме
інвест-клімат є одним із складових
Перемоги тому ми будемо захищати
економіку як роботодавців так і людей
праці проте всі чотири роки в парламенті
ми були цієї політичної силою яка
захищала реформи попередніх років яка
захищала і громадян і Бізнес від тиску і
саме найголовніше від несправедливості
Чи вдалося все звісно ні та все ж Нам
вдалось ще раз поправки до ряду законів
захистити малий і середній бізнес під
час боротьби з ковід спростити процедури
забезпечення всім необхідним і громадян
і заклади охорони здоров'я надати
додаткову фінансову підтримку громадянам
які потребували дороговартісного
лікування після початку
широкомасштабного наступу на нашу країну
захист волонтерів їх роботи забезпе
можливостей для благодійників які
спрямували всі зусилля на підтримку
Збройних сил через зміну податкових
правил і митних правил і ця робота
продовжується і на сьогодні Нам вдалося
навіть змінити ряд норм що стосувалися
Міністерства оборони як основного
розпорядника коштів для забезпечення
збройних сил України
вдалося не допустити втрату бюджету
через зменшення податків для грального
бізнесу через надання додаткових
несправедливих пільг з окремих питань
через звільнення від сплати військового
збору власників офшорних компаній це
наша була принципова позиція яка
забезпечила мільярди додаткових
надходжень бюджет
Так ми запропонували цю норму і вона
була прийнята в залі і її не було раніше
тому Нам вдалось провести саме цю норму
вдалось зупинити погіршення податкових
митних інших процедур для бізнесу ми
зупинили впровадження ряду корупційних
та дискримінаційних механізмів є питання
і проекти щодо яких нас не почули це
щодо стабільності і прогнозованості
податкових законодавства щодо спрощення
та покращення процедур для бізнесу що
для щодо захисту прав платників та
сервісні опції для платників податків
окремої уваги заслуговує акцент чи не
найбільшу проблему для бізнесу це
масштабне блокування податкових
накладних
в результаті спотворення системи яка
мала боротися з порушниками
законодавства більшість до пропорядних
платників страждає від зупинки
діяльності і вимивання обігових коштів
така ж проблема з автоматичним
відшкодуванням ПДВ створена система в ті
роки не тільки не відповідає базовим
нормам а напряму чомусь залежить від
бажання чи небажання чиновників із влади
і це питання над якими ми працюємо щодня
для того щоб прибрати цю
несправедливість яка досягла величезних
масштабів в останній рік
ми маємо звернути вашу увагу на те що
починаючи з бюджету на
2020 рік ми почали працювати над тими
статтями видатків Які би можна і
потрібно було спрямувати на забезпечення
посилення спроможності збройних сил
України і насправді
Петро Олексійович звернув увагу на той
проект закону який ми дуже просили
прийняти в залі це проект закону від 24
січня
2022 року де наша політична сила
запропонувала додаткових 50 млрд грн
спрямувати виключно на підсилення
спроможності наших збройних сил України
і Очевидно це дало би набагато більше
можливостей бути готовими до Широкого
наступу уже через місяць 22 лютого 2022
року а якщо Перелічити всі проекти
закону де ми боролися за спрямування
коштів саме для Міністерства оборони для
інших підрозділів збройних сил то їх
дуже багато і насправді останній проект
закону який стосується змін до бюджету
на 2023 рік яким ми пропонуємо
перерозподілити
ці додаткові кошти які без яких можуть
обійтися певні розпорядники це 90 і 70-х
мільярдів гривень і чи не на часі саме
зараз спрямувати їх туди де вони
найбільш потрібні тому
в нас починається п'ятий рік роботи в
парламенті і наша команда у складі 27
народних депутатів
ще принесе Я впевнена багато норм і
багато користі для наших і платників
податків і для економіки в цілому і
найголовніше про те з чого я розпочала
нам треба чітко мати програму захисту
внутрішнього інвестора захисту нових
можливостей для нових інвестицій який
буде вкрай потребувати наша країна
попереду п'ятий рік роботи і ми
докладемо всіх зусиль для того щоб
економіка країни була однією із
складових нашої Перемоги
Доброго дня шановні колеги справді Одним
із завдань з яким Наша команда йшла в
парламент в 2019 році було захистити
здобутки гуманітарної політики того що
ми разом з вами робили від 2014 по 2019
рік тоді після Революції гідності країна
під керівництвом президента Порошенка
зробила справжній ривок історичний ривок
в політиці зміцнення національної
ідентичності
в 2019 році наші здобутки опинилися під
загрозою під загрозою політиків які йшли
заходили в парламент під гаслами Какая
разница і нам справді довелося докласти
дуже багато зусиль для того щоб спинити
спроби змінити закон про функціональні
українською мовою як державної для того
щоб спинити спроби якимось чином змінити
закон про декомунізацію ми відстояли ці
ключові для нашої команди і для країни
закони часом нам доводилося звертатися і
до громадськості З часом все виливалося
в масштабні громадські протести коли
люди виходили на вулицю разом з нами
захи дуже важливий для країни закони але
врешті-решт ці закони продовжують
функціонувати більш того після 24 лютого
22-го року нам попри те що ми є
абсолютно в матчі цю в цьому парламенті
попри те що в нас є фракція яка
складається лише з 27 депутатів але
фракція яка є справді парламентські
спецназом про що сказав Петро
Олексійович ми зуміли нав'язати
продовження цієї політики з місця
національної ідентичності навіть цьому
парламенту саме після 24 лютого 22-го
року було ухвалено надзвичайно важливий
закон з нашої ініціативи який продовжує
процеси декомунізації це закон про
деколонізацію Я дуже радий що цим
парламентом було ухвалено закони які
забороняють музичні продукти
держава-агресору який забороняють книжку
держава-агресора Я дуже радий що було
ухвалено закони які підтримують
українську книжку українських
книговидання і українське книгу
розповсюдження Я дуже радий що врешті це
парламентом було ухвалено рішення і про
кращі пенсії для тих які боролися за
незалежність
насправді зробили багато для зміцнення
українського національного ідентичності
саме тепер в тій війні коли вона
переросла в повномасштабну війну тому що
прекрасно розуміємо що це крім всього
іншого це ще й війна за ідентичність нам
попри те що знову таки ми є опозиційною
фракцією невеликою опозиційною фракцією
в цьому парламенті вдалося Вплинути і
навіть на дуже важливий для нас кадрові
питання скандально відомі міністри які
очевидно На жаль були інструментами
політики спрямовані проти зміцнення
українського національного ідентичності
такі як Міністр освіти шкарлет подав
відставку Сьогодні ми дізналися про те
що врешті пішов у відставку йде у
відставку міністр культури інформаційної
політики Ткаченко саме один з цих
творців так званого єдиного марафону
який На жаль перетворився в інструмент
скорочення і придушення свободи слова в
Україні але попри ті здобутки Що ми
зробили очевидно нам іще є що робити
Зокрема я в цьому парламенті одна з
надзвичайно важливих питань на якому вже
акцентував свою увагу і Петро
Олексійович це питання припинення
діяльності в Україні російського
православної церкви зако проект який
власне має регулювати це який має
поставити крапку в існування цієї п'ятої
колони на території України нами нашої
фракцією подано до парламенту що в кінці
Минулого року цей законопроект було
підтримано комітетом фаховому комітетом
з питань гуманітарної та інформаційної
політики і на жаль досі не ставиться на
порядок даних парламент але очевидно що
ми будемо продовжувати дотискати тому що
вважаємо що це теж надзвичайно важливий
елемент національної ідентичності а
відтак і національної безпеки Я
впевнений що нам це вдасться Я впевнена
що ми робимо Україну сильнішою і
наближаємо до перемоги Слава Україні
героям
Слава 27 штиків я скажу что фракція
монобільшості приблизно 240 чоловік Але
тим не менше завдяки професійності
завдяки
мотивованості
державницькій позиції
ці 27 штиків ці 27 народних депутатів
дуже часто в цьому парламенті робили
дива так не все вдалося тому що
порівняйте 27 і 240 Але тим не менше з
першого дня ми боролися за
справедливість з першого дня ми
продовжували нашу боротьбу за армію
сектор безпеки оборони з першого дня ми
боролися за захист демократії збереження
реформ і проти узурпації влади
нагадаю що саме європейська Солідарність
була лідером
громадськості коли ми не дали владі
перетнути червоні лінії в 19-му році ми
відбили безліч нападок на мовою культуру
за 20-21
ми активно боролися проти п'ятої колони
ми активно піднімали питання крадіжок
сковідного фонду та на дорожньому
будівництві
24 лютого 22-го року вся фракція як один
взяла в руки зброю і влилася до лав
територіальної оборони
і чоловіки і жінки
всі залишилися на місці і активно
працювали в парламенті між іншим
ініціатива зібратися вранці 24-го саме в
пленарній залі парламенту це була
ініціатива європейської солідарності
виконання гімну народними депутатами на
початку кожного засідання що зараз стало
вже традицією розпочалося після
ініціативи
Володимира в'ятровича 24 лютого
22-го року
Ми тримаємо Єдність і наша єдність
завжди буде Заради перемоги заради армії
заради шляху європейських Союз та нато
але єдності не буде там де яйця по 17
гривень Де зникають десятки мільярдів
гривень спрямовані на закупівлю
озброєння де кладуть асфальт замість
допомоги збройним силам України
ми постійно захищали справедливість ми
постійно захищали армію ми боролися за
те щоб фінансування армії було
максимально можливим і я вам скажу що в
22-му році ми контролювали слідкували і
жорстко змушували часто спрямовувати
десятки мільярдів гривень саме на сектор
безпеки оборони замість інших нібито
важливих потреб що може бути важливіше
підтримки бійців і офіцерів сьогодні Та
що вже говорити якщо 23-го року саме
завдяки європейській солідарності ми
змусили зняти 2 млрд з ПДФО які вони
хотіли розпиляти І спрямувати на
підтримку Збройних Сил України 23-й рік
підкреслюю ми змусили їх повернути 30
тисяч виплат значній частині
військовослужбовців і ще продовжимо цю
боротьбу ми змусили їх проголосувати за
відпустки і зараз боремося за багато
інших питань підтримки армії
попереду дуже багато роботи все Заради
перемоги все заради збереження України і
нашої національної ідентичності все
заради того щоб шлях до єсенато був
якомога скорішим і ми зробимо все для
того щоб це прийшло до нас
якомога скоріше Дякую за увагу
Шановні колеги закон Про статус
народного депутата України вимагає від
кожного депутата звітувати після кожної
парламентської сесії і зараз ви почули
традиційний і дуже важливий класичний
звіт нашої фракції він не повний Це була
презентація звіту Закликаємо вас
підписуватися на наш телеграм-канал на
нашу сторінку в Фейсбуці де сьогодні
наша пресслужба викладе повний звіт про
роботу фракції пройти тисячі законів
якими ініціювали депутатські запити
звернення роботу в регіонах відрядження
для того щоб кожен виборець
європейського солідарності і виборить
інших політичних сил бачив чим жила наша
фракція ці чотири роки очевидно що
депутати мають звітувати а не серіалами
займатися і тому сподіваємося наш
приклад стане прикладом для інших колег
в першу чергу Моне більшості тому що в
першу чергу має звітувати влада і колеги
Мені здається подали дуже грунтовний
звіт щодо нашої роботи прикро що часто
палки в колеса ставили хвилини випускали
Порошенка на міжнародні заходи можливо
боючись А що він там буде вимагати
прискорити на шлях до є сенато але це
дійсно сьогодні є наша об'єднуюча ідея
чи коли крали наше законопроекти
переписуючи їх не під правильними
прізвищами не можеш закон про дев'ятий
травня бути відветровича або закони про
армію умову Віру від Порошенка але як
любить цитувати Володі ветрович це
цитата з Степана Бандери перемагаємо ми
тоді коли перемагають наші ідеї ідея
армія мова Віра є сената - це сьогодні
дійсно об'єднуюча ідея і Наша команда не
має права її зрадити тому що дві з
половиною тисячі наших партійців
сьогодні на фронті 51
в тому числі серед них дуже близькі Наші
друзі наші колеги депутати місцевих
органів влади загинули на фронті серед
них і колишній депутати наш дорогий
колега Барна Ми не маємо права зрадити
їх пам'яті тому будемо робити все для
того щоб дійсно в Україні була
демократія свобода слова і ми рухалися
до єсената знаєте в суспільстві
популярна така фраза от повернуться
хлопці і дівчата з фронту наведуть лад
це дуже інфантильна позиція яка точно не
сприймається нашою політичною командою
ми знаємо наше завдання Сьогодні щодня
працювати на те щоб армія була
захищена щоб там були Вибачте нормальні
зарплати нормальні соціальні виплати щоб
там була відпустка 30 днів щоб та
волонтерська допомога яка передається
від наших країн в тому числі машини з
правостороннім кермом ставилися там на
облік і це все наше здобутки звичайно
цей звіт мав би спілкуватися в ефірі
телеканалу рада але сьогодні він
відданий в лізинг офісу президента І от
ви знаєте що добре щось із президента
погано що вони забрали канал Рада бо це
не демократично але вони читають наші
соцмережі читають наші позицію і після
вимоги європейської солідарності щодо
відставки пана Ткаченка а також того що
там треба розібратися з діяльністю цього
Міністерства як і шкарлута ці відставки
відбуваються хоч дуже дивно що це
анонсує президент бо мова йде про
парламентського президентську республіку
і тут би про це мали говорити
монобільшість Але маємо те що маємо
чотири роки мовчазного парламенту Який
Ну просто втрачає свою суб'єктність тому
що набрали Ну на жаль дуже часто
випадкових таких знаєте безуглих людей
але як є хочу сказати що я буду говорити
про майбутнє Наша команда планує зробити
все для того щоб цього року розпочалися
офіційні перемовини для членства України
в ЄС тому в порядку денному мають стоя і
закон про конституційний суд саме того
авторства яке ми подавали Що півтора
роки тому і закон про антимонопольне
законодавство тому що це наближає
боротьбу з олігархами а не ці закони які
ну знаєте видавалися за відповідне ви
знаєте Ми зробимо все для того щоб
олігархів з бюджету України не годували
прості громадяни тому що сьогодні дійсно
два мільярди гривень ідуть на
олігархічні телеканали і ми запитуємо
виборців не тільки європейської
солідарності на кожного українця А ви за
це підписувалися що ваші кошти ідуть на
марафон-олігархічний де люди ну точно ці
олігархи можуть дозволити собі
фінансувати серіали що завгодно канал
Рада має транслювати засідання Верховної
Ради тому що має бути підзвітність має
бути прозорість і журналісти повинні
повернутися в кулуари парламенту Ми
також зробимо все для того щоб в Україні
було не тільки Міністерство ветеранів а
й ветеранська політика тому що ми
сьогодні будемо Україною ветеранів і це
несправедливо що сьогодні цим ніхто
займається Ми сьогодні країна безіменний
героїв тому що герої в нас там хто
паровознюк який з вагнером хіба що
вагнерівцями може змагатись по кількості
матюків в прямому ефірі але там немає
тих людей Марафоні які реально сьогодні
воюють від своє життя за Україну і ми
зробимо все для того щоб їх пам'ять
вшанувати незалежно від партійних
прапорів тому що дійсно В окопах люди не
говорять про те Хто за кого голосував
хто кого підтримує там всі працюють під
одним прапором під українським так само
як наша команда європейського
солідарності дорогі виборці Дорогі
українці для нас є висока честь і довіра
працювати ці чотири роки під нашим
мандатом Ми дякуємо вам за неї і Повірте
щодня Ми пам'ятаємо про армію мову Віру
ЄС і Ната і зробимо все для того щоб ця
наша передвиборча платформа ну яка тепер
об'єднала країну була реалізована тому і
закони про те що заборона тут
Московської цієї церкви п'ятої колони
обов'язково буде в порядку денному якщо
наш закон від себе захоче подати пан
Зеленський ми не проти ми за це
проголосуємо дякуємо за увагу Дякую
Слава збройним силам України і слава
Україні героям слава